I had some lucky James I mean I was born
at the right time if I'd been born
thousands of years ago in some animals
lunch cuz I can't run very fast or climb
trees so there's so much chance and how
we enter the world it really kind of
made me think about how now the probably
bringing Warren along is my dad is that
he has about 80 chances but that's a
four oh I think he's telling me that but
you know most people really have about
forty good years you get through school
you get a little experience and you
think about the goals you want to
accomplish and and the legacy you want
to build or whatever it is you want to
do my kids could do nothing and and
instead they've all three of them have
elected to spend every day and in
Howie's case enormous effort in helping
other people and I just think that
survey makes me feel very good I have
been inspired really actually by both my
grandfather and my father and Howard is
my dad has taken me around the world
with him over the last 15 years and
showing me exactly yeah we've had a
couple of places I won't go here a lot
of don't tell Dad yeah they love it but
you know grandpa grandpa has really been
a role model for what one person can
accomplish in a lifetime and the same
with that how do you envision it work
well let's say okay we'll start with me
dying tomorrow morning and it's not
morning directors or directors would
would meet probably by telephone
initially and and they know exactly who
they would put in the CEO and that CEO
will be terrific and in many many
respects much better than I am
and they would make Howie the
non-executive chairman but that will
take no more time really than being a
director takes now
there are more good things going on out
in the country the rest of the country
that in Washington I'll put it that way
the Forbes 400 this year came in at 2
trillion 20 billion that that's far
higher than any year in the past it's
it's 20 22 or 23 times what it was 30
years ago so the wealthy are doing fine
more than fine yeah but the inequality
is grown and and that is something I
think that the Congress ought to take
very seriously we won't have another
shutdown but that's a very very minor
triumph I mean the fact that we don't
shut down the United States government
should not be looked at as a crowning
achievement of this particular Congress
so on the we have the resources of Betty
I mean we we have a country with $50,000
of GDP per capita that's six times what
it was when I was born if you told my
father when he was in the waiting room
in 1930 that his son was going to live
in a world that had six times as much
stuff per person he would have thought
we would all be living in Utopia even a
rich family can make too many promises
but we we should never forget we've got
a wonderfully rich family and the
question is is how we take care of that
family and at the same time have the
family continue to get richer we want it
the market system is wonderful in terms
of producing more and more stuff and the
question is how do we make sure
everybody that it is part of the family
that has this stuff at least has a very
decent minimum standard of living I love
Vince Gilligan but I couldn't get it out
of a man it was I thought it was a
terrific ending and you know Walter
White's going on his reward but maybe I
can be a successor who knows I've never
seen it because I never get to watch TV
there's no TVs on the combine I mean
that's the really other job more you're
always great on this I wanted to bring
up the main characters of Breaking Bad
okay who do you identify with people
would probably think I probably saw the
lawyer 12 cellphone
all right